[Music]
caleb's in oklahoma city hi caleb what's
up
how are you guys doing today better than
we deserve merry christmas
merry christmas
all right so let's get on with my
problem
i bought a car i thought i could afford
back in july
i got it repo'd yesterday and i leave to
go to the military next month now about
29 ish thousand dollars what should i do
should i
go and get it out of the repo and sell
it or should i just default the loan and
pay the difference
wow
how old are you
i'm 19 years old
and you know 29 000 car loan
yes sir what was your payment
uh
685 a month
yeah and what do you make
i make
a little over two thousand dollars a
month
that's painful
very
so i'm happy to answer your question um
tell me what you learned from this
experience
i learned to ask for help when i need it
and uh
don't buy materialistic things because
you can
you can
buy a cheap car
15-inch thousand dollars and not have a
payment on it
now i'm worrying about the next step
what i have to do
in order to get myself out of this
buying that i put myself into yeah
okay
um
anybody tell you not to buy this car
uh actually
everybody but i went against everybody's
word and said you know what i can do it
and here i am couldn't do it
who uh told you not to buy it that you
think you now can trust for advice on
this type of thing
my girlfriend my girlfriend's dad and
both my parents yeah i'm going with your
dad
so one of the things you learn is um
that
you know when there's a whole
the bible says in the multitude of
counsel
there is safety
and you had a multitude of counsel
telling you not to do this
and so that's one of the lessons i
learned by the way when i went broke
was um that there is a time to go
against uh what everybody in quotes says
and there's a time when everybody in
your life that loves you is saying don't
do this that you need it needs to give
you pause and so
uh nowadays i gather
uh opinions and i not only just what the
opinion is okay do you say don't not to
buy it now tell me why i shouldn't do
this and so i learned from the wisdom of
these people around me and sometimes i
choose to discount it because they're
why they're telling me it doesn't make
sense okay but in your case they would
have said you can't afford it a six
hundred dollar payment on two thousand
dollars is silly a thirty thousand
dollar car for 19 years old making
um two thousand dollars a month is is
out of control i mean these are the
things they would have said to you if
you'd ask why you're saying i shouldn't
buy it and then you it would have led
you away so the trick is to not it's
it's horrible to go through this it's
much more horrible to go through it
two times or three times because you
didn't learn your lesson that's why i
wanted to ask you about that okay
yes sir okay now here's what's going to
happen
they're going to sell the car on a repo
lot
and they're going to come after you for
the difference
it's called the deficit
balance
and so if they sold the car for
i'll just make up a number uh nine
thousand dollars they'll come after you
for twenty thousand dollars if they sell
it for nineteen thousand they're gonna
come after you for ten thousand you see
what i'm talking about
yes sir they will then settle that with
you after they've been trying to collect
from you and realize you are a broke
young guy in the military that makes no
money
they're going to realize they're not
going to get that money from you
most of the time they don't get the
deficit from the person they can't get
it out of them because the person's
broke thus their car got repo'ed okay
yeah so they're kind of used to this in
other words the people trying to collect
from you
um and so if you'll let it sit six
months or more
from the time they first contact you
talk to them and just go on broke i
can't pay it
and then let them just let them wallow
around for about six months they'll
settle for somewhere around 25 cents on
the dollar
so you've got about a year
to save up
25 of what you think the deficit is
going to be
what do you think the car is worth
23 thousand dollars it's a 2018 ford
mustang if it sells for 19 you'll be
lucky on the repo lot
so you need three
four or five thousand dollars in an
account
to settle
this with them and then you will have a
repo'd car on your credit
and you will have a settled
bad debt on your credit that you settled
the deficit with them
okay
and that will do the minimal amount of
damage to your pocketbook and to your
credit and then you can begin to move
forward and from this point forward if
you want to be rich pay cash for cars
rich people don't take car payments out
and that's how they got rich
i understood okay
george anything you want to add well it
just reminded me of of the verse you
know adults devise a plan
and children do what feels good and
right now i'm talking
to a kid but you're about to go serve
our country enter the military you're an
adult and so i just want you to start
making adult decisions and do what's
best for your financial future so when
you come back you can't afford a fifteen
thousand dollar car like you mentioned
you're gonna save up and pay cash for
maybe a three thousand dollar car and
upgrade it over time and you're gonna
stay out of debt you're gonna have an
emergency fund so that you never have to
deal with this again so that you can
build wealth so that you can be a 25
year old guy who's married with a family
who leaves an incredible legacy so i
want you to start thinking about your
future and the kind of man you want to
be and the kind of future you want to
have yeah
now we've all we've all done stupid
stuff like this caleb and so me included
i did it with zeros on the end so we're
not picking on you in that regard um the
trick is to not my my goal in my life is
don't do the same stupid thing twice
there's enough new stupid things to do
without doing the same one twice and so
learn from it right learn from it and
don't go do the same one again and and
this one is about debt and about buying
things against the multitude of counsel
and um you know that takes you in the
right direction that's a sad story yeah
it's a harsh
thing thank you for serving your country
too we appreciate you
i remember being 19 and thinking
whatever people told me not to do i
wanted to do it even more i'm still that
guy i still have a challenge i mean i
make most of my living going against
convention right
the things we teach here are
perpendicular to cultural norms
and beliefs that's not bad
but uh but what is bad is when you have
people of wisdom
all around you saying don't do that
don't do that don't do that you go i'm
doing it anyway you know and man haven't
we all done that i've i've done that so
many times and every time it leaves a
mark yeah
you won't do that though well i've i
haven't done stupid with as many zeros
as you have no few have very few you're
impressive in that regard
but like you mentioned my goal too
today that was it i got up this morning
i said i hope i can impress george today
oh i bet
looked in the mirror that's what you
said the first thing out of my mind but
it's a good principle are you going to
learn from this what are you going to do
after this is all over and you've
cleaned this mess up are you going to
make another mess
well it is an interesting thing to think
about um
that what is the difference
between standing against a cultural norm
that is
universally dumb like everybody says you
need a credit score so do you go get a
credit score no that's not what we're
saying
uh but on the other hand being able to
take the input
of wise people in the multitude of
council their safety so
what you want to do is um
if you're taking counsel from other
people multitudes in other words you're
going to get four or five people's input
on a decision
ask them why they're saying should i do
this no
okay why
and then line up their whys and really
what you're learning from is the whys
and if someone says you need a credit
score so well why
well because you need to be able to get
into debt well why
so you can get further into debt well
why so you can get further into debt
well that's i'm not following that
okay but if if i get logical good
critical thinking skill answers back
when i ask why
and they start to line up across several
people then i go oh well this is
starting to make sense then the y's will
make you wise you see what i did there i
saw that that's a nice twist thank you
well played